>> WELCOME BACK.
MILLENNIAL'S AT WORK DON'T.
UP THE PHONE.
A NEW BRITISH SURVEY MUCH LIKE
REGULAR SURVEY BUT WITH BAD TV.
FINDS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO
BAN PHONE CALLS OF THE OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY FIND THEM TOO
AGGRESSIVE AND CONFRONTATIONAL.
THE SAME REASONS THAT SHANNON
BREAM WAS BANNED FROM WALMART.
75% OF OFFICE WORKERS SAY THEY
PREFER COMMUNICATING VIA E-MAIL
OR SOCIAL MEDIA, WHICH THEY FIN
LESS STRESSFUL AND EASIER FOR
SENDING [BLEEP].
HERE IS MINE.
DICK VAN DYKE, DICK YORK, MY
FAVORITE, BEWITCHED AND THAT IS
DICK SARGENT, THE SECOND DICK
FROM BEWITCHED.
APPARENTLY THE DESIGN --
THE DESIRE TO BAN CALLS IS FROM
THE GYM C CROWD WHICH PREFER
TEXTING INSTEAD.
THEY GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
AVOID FACE-TO-FACE CONTACT.
AND BRIAN KILMEADE'S CASE
COMMITTED IS 10 OUT OF 10.
ALL OF THIS IS DUE TO TECHNOLOGY
.
THE GUY BEHIND THE SURVEY WARNE
US NOT JUST YOUNG PEOPLE THAT H
CALLS, ADDING, QUOTE, WHILE
YOUNGER OFFICE WORKERS PREFER
MESSAGING TO TALKING, ACROSS AG
GROUPS THERE'S A FEELING THAT
PHONE CALLS HAVE A TENDENCY TO
BE CONFRONTATIONAL.
HE CALLED US JERKS AND HUNG UP.
SO IF IT'S SOMEONE YOU DON'T
LIKE THE CALLS YOU, THERE'S AN
EASY SOLUTION FOR EVERYONE BAN
THE F UP.
EXCUSE ME, PERSON THE F UP.
>> [PHONE RINGS]
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT?
I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THAT
[BLEEP].
ALRIGHT, GOODBYE.
SHE SAYS THAT TO ME EVERY DAY.
I HAVE TO DO THIS THAT I HAVE T
DO THAT.
I DON'T WANT ALL THIS.
>> KAT, IT IS AMAZING WHAT HAIR
AND MAKEUP DOES TO YOU.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> CAN YOU SPEAK FOR ALL
MILLENNIAL'S EVERYWHERE?
WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM, WITH
CONFRONTATION.
PHONE CALLS ARE CONFRONTATIONAL.
THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE.
WHEN SOMEBODY CALLS ME I'M LIKE
WHY IS SOMEBODY CALLING MY TEXT
MESSAGE MACHINE.
AT I ASSUME SOMEBODY DIED.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> OF WHAT I DO, I DON'T ANSWER
AND I WAIT A FEW MINUTES AND I
TEXT THEM AND SAY WHAT'S UP.
>> YOU'RE HOPING IT'S NOT REALL
BAD.
>> WHY ARE YOU CALLING ME.
I HAVE TO PREPARE FOR THAT.
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS SCARIER
THAN THAT.
>> WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING.
HE JUST PUNCHED ME IN THE FACE.
>> YOU KNOW, TYRUS, YOU ARE IN
THE OFFICE ON THE 21st FLOOR
NEXT TO JUDGE JEANINE.
DO YOU FIND IT WEIRD IN THE
OFFICE THAT YOU STILL HAVE AN
OFFICE DESK PHONE?
EACH ONE OF US HAS A DESK PHONE.
HAVE YOU EVER USED IT?
>> NO.
THAT'S NOT TROOP HERE USUALLY
WHEN JUDGE JEANINE COMES BY, I
USUALLY GRAB IT.
CHANCES ARE SHE WANTS ME TO MOV
OUR LIFT SOMETHING.
INSPECTION FOOT AND ASK YOU
ABOUT HUGH FEEL ABOUT SOMETHING.
AFTER YOUR CRITICIZE, YOU FEEL
BETTER.
IS LIKE THE GRANDMA I NEVER
ASKED FOUR.
>> WE ARE JUST BRITTLE.
NO ONE WANTS ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF PHONE CALLS.
IT'S YOUR JOB PICK IF YOU DON'T
WANT A PHONE CALL AT HOME,
THAT'S FINE.
BUT IF YOUR CUSTOMER SERVICE,
YOU'VE GOT TO ANSWER THE PHONE.
YOU WANT TO TEXT MESSAGE YOU GE
BACK TO WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE AT
HER AND E-MAIL AND IS LIKE A
E-MAIL THREE TIMES ABOUT GETTIN
THIS FIXED.
LET ME CHECK MY SPAM PICTURE CA
END UP CALLING ANYWAY BECAUSE
THEY ARE TOO LAZY TO DO ANYTHING
.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN IF
SOMETHING GOES WRONG, IF THE
WORLD STOPS?
>> THEN YOU CAN CALL ME.
>> I DO LOVE CUSTOMER CHATS.
WHEN YOU ARE ON SEAMLESS --
>> AND YOU'D LEAVE A SCATHING
MESSAGE.
>> ADAM, I HATE YOUNG PEOPLE AN
I SUSPECT I'M NOT ALONE ON THIS.
FOR IT YOU FALL ON THIS?
>> I HATE PHONE CALLS MYSELF.
IF THAT IS SUCH CONFRONTATIONAL
THE CONFRONTATIONAL ASPECT OF I
DON'T MEAN TEXTING, I JUST DON'
LIKE BEING INTRUSIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK TO YOU
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN I HAD ELLEN LEAVE VOICEMAI
ON MY PHONE, IT WAS LIKE I REAC
ADAM.
I'VE JUST NEVER ANSWERED MY
PHONE.
I AVOID THEM.
WHERE IT'S REALLY HARD TO SIT I
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE I DON'T
LIKE TALKING ON THE PHONE AT AL
AND GIRLS I'VE DATED IN FULL GE
OFFENDED BY THAT.
IS NOT THAT I DON'T WANT TO TAL
TO YOU ON THE PHONE COME IT'S
THAT I DON'T WANT TO TALK TO
ANYONE INCLUDING YOU ON THE
PHONE.
>> DIDN'T WORK?
>> IT WORKS.
THE RELATIONSHIP ENDED.
>> I WAS GOING TO TRY THAT.
JULIE, THAT IS YOUR NAME, RIGHT?
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT NOW
WE BELIEVE THAT A PHONE CALL IS
OBTRUSIVE WHEREAS WHEN WE
HAVEN'T REALLY CHANGED, 20-30
YEARS AGO, THE PHONE RANG AND
YOU PICKED FF AND NOW IT IS LIK
IT IS STAR 69.
REMEMBER THAT.
I LOVE THAT.
>> I'M ONLY A COUPLE YEARS AWAY
FROM BEING --
SO I CAN SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT
--
SCREW Q YOU.
I HATE THAT.
THAT AUTOMATICALLY DOESN'T WORK.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> I HATE PHONE CALLS, SO IF YO
CALL ME, YOU BETTER BE DYING.
MY MOM WILL CALL ME AND I SEND
HER TO VOICEMAIL BUT I WILL TEX
HER BACK IN THAT IS EVERYTHING
OKAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE SHE IS NOT
HAVING A HEART ATTACK BUT OF TH
SAME TIME DON'T CALL ME UNLESS
YOU HAVE MADE A RESERVATION TO
APPOINTS ALL TALK, I WOULD WALK
TO THE LOBBY F THIS BUILDING
LIKE LOOKING AS UNAPPROACHABLE
AS POSSIBLE.
LIKE MABLY TEXTING IN ON THE
PHONE OF THE SAME TIME.
>> DOES BARRY EVER GET THE
MESSAGE?
>> NO.
>> I'M GLAD YOU ENJOYED IT.
WHERE THE ONLY ONE LAUGHING.
>> COMPANY PHONES.
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
DIRTY THE PHONES ARE.
WHEN I WORKED IN PENNSYLVANIA,
WE WERE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH OU
PHONES AND THEY OPENED THEM UP
AND ATTACK CAME UP AND SAID
THERE WERE COCKROACHES LIVING
INSIDE THEIR PHONES.
I LOVE TELLING PEOPLE THAT STORY
.
AND ON THAT NOTE --
IT WAS A BIG COMPANY